Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David P..
You can leave a voicemail about anything.
Here is a voicemail that was left
pointing out the continued so-called
free speech confusion that many on the
right are experiencing. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: David, why do conservatives constantly
Speaker 4: cry about free speech? But they
never seem to realize that that only applies
to what the federal government does. Why don't
they just argue for amending the Constitution
to apply those same rules to private companies?
Speaker 1: Well, because they don't necessarily
know that. Yeah, so this is a very important
thing. Free speech is sometimes used colloquially
just to say me saying whatever I want, wherever
I want with no consequences and nobody having an
ability to limit what I'm allowed to say. Now, of
course, when you're on a platform that has terms
of service and you're not being discriminated
against because of your race or religion or
whatever, the platform can enforce terms of
service. And this is a good point that when
we talk about the First Amendment, we are
talking about government limiting speech.
Does the bulk of the right wing realize that
when we talk about my First Amendment right
to free speech, it doesn't apply to Twitter?
Some of them might, but many of them don't.
But the next question is a good one. Why don't
they just say? First Amendment rights should apply
to private companies of all kinds, and the reason
some of them don't do it is because they don't
even understand what we're talking about. OK, put
those aside. The reason more prominent Republicans
don't suggest that is they realize that it
actually is a dangerous, slippery slope. You know,
I make a point to signal when the fear of a
slippery slope is unwarranted, there's lots.
For example, they would say, Oh, the vaccine
mandates are going to open the door to what,
all sorts of authoritarianism? It hasn't happened.
We've had vaccine requirements in this country for
100 years. And even when it comes to the COVID
vaccine mandates, they've mostly been relaxed.
The Supreme Court said no to Biden's, but it was
there was no slippery slope there. They're just
historically, we knew there wouldn't be common
sense. We knew there wouldn't be when it comes
to this entire absolute free speech applied to all
companies, period. It actually would be a crazy,
slippery slope when it comes to an employer's
ability to limit workers from speaking customers.
It it would actually be an insanely heavy
handed form of the regulation of businesses,
and many Republicans realize that. And that's
why they will vaguely say, Oh, you know,
we've got two conservatives got to make sure
that we have a voice on platforms and whatever,
but they typically stopped short of that
extremely authoritarian at the end of the day,
claim or request that free speech should apply
to any private company the way it does to the
government because they understand the very
serious repercussions and they understand it
would be completely counter to their view of let
businesses do what they want to do as long as it's
not against the law and sometimes even if it is.
Many Republicans know that smarter Republicans
recognize that, and that's why they don't say,
let's regulate companies in the exact same way
when it comes to speech as the government is
regulated by the First Amendment. We have a great
bonus show for you today. We will talk about
the Super Bowl halftime show. I have a number
of different thoughts about it. Congressional
staffers are organizing a union. We will tell
you why and whether it's likely to succeed, and
we will talk about the latest in the Sarah Palin
New York Times defamation case. It's getting very
interesting. Make sure you sign up now really at
join Pacman dot com and get instant access
Unidentified: to the bonus track.